Hubble Whole Foods the grocery chain
that revolutionized our expectations of
supermarkets be affected by its recent
merger with Amazon the online retail
giant can conscious capitalism the
high-minded philosophy of Whole Foods
co-founder and CEO John Mackey survived
a partnership with a company known for
its relentless pursuit of cost savings
and growth that's what was on our mind
most when Reason sat down with Mackey at
Liberty Cod the annual meeting of
students for Liberty in a wide-ranging
conversation Mackey talks candidly about
the Amazon merger and the stockholder
activism that drove him to seek the deal
in the first place how his ethical
veganism and hardcore libertarianism
inform one another and why he's
optimistic about both the future of
Commerce and the idealism of young
Americans hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV and we are sitting down with
the co-founder and CEO of Whole Foods
John Mackey a great friend to Liberty
and to students for liberty we're
filming this at these students for
Liberty's Liberty con 2018 John thanks
for talking thanks for having me on Nick
good to see you
are you optimistic about young people in
general or is it that there's a certain
percentage because it seems when when
you listen to young people talk or the
way that they vote etc there's a certain
amount of kind of libertarian Brio there
which is like we'd like capitalism or we
like freedom because it allows us to
express our purpose in peaceful ways but
then there is a really resurgent or
insurgent group of young people on
college campuses and elsewhere who are
kind of in a Bernie Sanders camp yeah
you know how do you think that place I
think it's a good question and I think
there's two trends that are going on I
definitely think there's a
young people are idealistic cuz you know
the old saying that if you're not a
socialist when you're 21 you've got no
heart and if you're not a capitalist by
the time you're 30 up no brains and I
still think that plays out its young
people or they come of age they look
around they take for granted the
prosperity they take for granted the
ethical moral progress the manatees made
they look around and they say by God is
not perfect there are still racism
there's still poverty there's still
inequality the whole thing is unfair and
they're so they are susceptible to the
siren call of any type of utopian answer
that promises to fix it and make things
better but because they're not very
experienced and they don't know no
history very well they don't understand
how the bad get on top is Hayek said
that that utopian impulse of
perfectionism is you usually the enemy
of the good
so usually they grow out of that so I'm
not going to be too disturbed when I
hear utopian young people because I was
one and I grew out of it and you
probably won and you're probably gonna
grow out of it someday I'll grow out of
this mustache first but no no in all
seriousness and then but I also think
people are these young people when I
compared myself at the same age you know
if I go back a long time ago 40 plus
years a lot of ways they're more
conscious and more awake than my
generation was at the same period of
time so I think there's reason for
optimism but of course you know I've
seen the polls too and and and 51
percent said they think socialism is
better than capitalism that is a very
disturbing statistic although I tend to
be somewhat skeptical pretty much
anything I read in the paper because or
the news because they so much hunger for
sensationalism and headlines and
clickbait and things like that and plus
somebody I get so many lives told about
me it's hard for me to believe anything
already so well this seems like a good
point to talk about the merger with
Amazon so Whole Foods is has merged with
Amazon is that a are you excited about
that and should consumers be excited
about it I'm super excited about it
so I'll tell you a brief story and and I
know that some people will will be
cynical about what I'm about to say but
I honestly believe it's a good metaphor
for it
so we were all fizz being harassed by
shareholder activists who were trying to
take over our board and they had an anti
campaign against me in the media they
were doing other things I had more time
and off-the-record all Sunday tell you
about but they were putting a lot of
pressure on our company to go up for
sale and we didn't really want to sell
it and necessarily but if we if we were
gonna be forced into a sale I wanted to
find absolutely the best possible
partner and not just be taken over by a
supermarket company that this wouldn't
necessarily share our values and our and
our views and wouldn't help us you need
to be honest so kind of a mutual friend
kind of introduced us and I had several
executive three executives fly out with
me to Seattle we met with Jeff Bezos and
three of his senior executives and you
know if when you've had the experience
of falling in love there there comes a
point where you have what I call the
conversation we may stay up all night
and you just have this real connections
kind of meeting of the soul so to speak
that happened on our first conversation
we were like thunderstruck they were so
smart and they were so authentic and we
were just like almost finishing each
other's sentences by the time when we
left there a few hours later and our
executive team went to a restaurant and
we were sitting around and it's like
those guys are incredible do you think
they liked us too
turned out they did the Amazon felt the
same way what was the and they had a
whole group of his exes come down four
days later to Austin and then literally
six weeks after that first meeting we'd
signed merger papers it went that fast
and we were we were married or merged
two months after that and what was the
common ground that clicked the common
ground is the following both companies
are very committed to our most important
stakeholder in both companies those
customers where we're about customers
are our most important stakeholder in
Amazon even goes beyond they're like
they're like there
core value is they're obsessed with
customers they always care about put the
customers first and so we we synced up
on that almost immediately
and then but both companies are very
innovative Whole Foods in the food
retailing business is very innovative
we're doing amazing things all the time
and Amazon of course admires us for that
and I don't know of a more innovative
company than Amazon they're like what
they've done and what they're doing is
is great so we were we thought you know
if we could get together we could read
identity beautiful children yes we're
gonna reinvent the supermarket business
as we know it we're gonna we're gonna
get food to people less expensively and
also both companies are really dedicated
to the long term view but Whole Foods
having pressure from shareholder
activists we were having to focus more
and more and more on the very short term
quarterly to quarterly earnings
something I swore we would never do but
I felt like maybe the company wasn't
gonna survive
Amazon's giving us the freedom to think
long term again it talked about when
when you open a store and I realized
that might change under the new
arrangement but you know typically when
you would open a store how long were you
thinking that that store would be there
for him what went how much money went
into it typical new store well we sign
usually signed 20 year lease and then
there's another options on that up to
another 10 to 20 years on top of that so
30 to 40 years is what we're usually
thinking with but we're locked in
usually for 20 years
so that's you got to take the long term
view when you're when you're investing
in this because this is to go back to
the kind of people who take capitalism
or profit for granted I mean it's always
like well of course you all you have to
do is put up a Whole Foods and then you
know people start backing up Brinks
trucks do and full of money but it's
it's a long term it I mean it's a long
term investment of your money at that
point it is and there's no guarantee the
store is going to be successful and all
of our stores haven't been successful
and you have competition that comes in
and take maybe gets a better location or
or in opens a bigger store undercut you
in price or
so it's it's very competitive out there
and you your customers they're not you
don't have a gun to their heads they
trade with you because it's in their
interest to do so and by the way if
better store comes along then they will
desert you in droves so you have to make
a long-term commitment you have to tie
your capital up for a long long time I
mean you asked how much we invest in the
store it depends on the size of the
store but generally anywhere from 8 to
20 plus million dollars for a new store
you mentioned that you Whole Foods in
Amazon have a fixation on customer kind
of satisfaction customer experience do
you think that in part explains the kind
of attacks on both companies and you
know the I mean this there's a lot going
on but it seems that the fixation on
customers it's got to be really
threatening to firms or to businesses
that have a pretty good deal going on
because you know having to you know when
somebody comes in and is like I'm gonna
give your customers a better deal better
service better prices that's got to be
threatening to be I think the companies
have been attacked for different reasons
I think Whole Foods is attacked because
we appeal to a better-educated generally
more affluent customer base and because
we're selling the highest quality food
it's frequently been more expensive so
some people feel like they're not
invited to the party they're not allowed
to participate and they are invited and
they are welcome to participate but they
still resent it and I remember because
particularly when Whole Foods started
out we were really kind of a really
counterculture company and we were one
venture capitalist who didn't chose not
to invest in who said I think you guys
are just a bunch of hippies selling food
to other hippies and I'm not going to
invest and it turned out the hippies
became yuppies and and they still
shopped with us but they started driving
BMWs and now they drive Tesla's and
things like that and that caused a lot
of resentment from people who were a
little less affluent and they booked
tend to blame us we also created very
beautiful stores so and we were it's an
aspirational store we're calling people
to change their diet to eat a
higher-quality food
most people want to change their diet
they feel like we're judging them that
we're saying something's wrong with them
we're not but that's how they experience
it so I think those are the reasons
Whole Foods is attack Amazon's attack
for a completely different reason nobody
can accuse Amazon of not of having high
prices because they're very very
competitive and they get they now you
know it's two-day delivery if you're a
Prime member and and I think Amazon's
attack because Amazon disrupts
industries they scare that they scare
industries that are fat and comfortable
and they shake them up no they did that
with books they're doing it with are
threatening to do with medicine now they
did it looks they did it with music they
done it they've done it with now you
know their video video now all types of
retailing in general now with Whole
Foods they threaten food and I ever I
can't read the paper any day where I
don't read about some new business
Amazons you know it's really an
interesting question given your you know
your retail guy and Amazon is an
e-commerce giant is you know in an
e-commerce still I mean when you look at
various ways to cut it but like you know
it accounts for maybe 1 out of 1 out of
10 sales you know in a given year maybe
you know 90% of Commerce is still done
you know people walking into a store I'm
walking out with something is retail on
you know is traditional retail dead and
and or is it dying it is dying yeah and
so what is there a way that the retail
space can still flourish and is it that
it has to be more of a destination for
the shop or more of an experience or
here's where I think people I get asked
where are we heading
here's where I think where we're heading
we're heading to people can get anything
they want at any time they want it
anywhere they want it at a price that
they're willing to pay and that's we're
heading and so that sounds like a pretty
good play it's a consumer utopia but
that means a lot of established
businesses are going to fail and that's
very scary and Amazon is identified as
the villain in the tale
not the villain as far as customers are
concern or consumers they're making our
lives better but the powers that have
the economic powers did a political
clout they don't want to be disrupted
and they will go the government and
scream for protection or stop this
merger or prevent this Amazon needs to
be investigating me be looked into
that's all just vested economic interest
trying to use the coercive power of
government to protect themselves from
competition in the run-up to election
2016 you were a big Rand Paul guy you're
you know friendly towards Gary Johnson
or at least the knows now but what about
Trump do you think I guess two questions
one are you do you think Trump year-plus
and is better than Hillary would have
been and how is he not as a person I
mean he's a he's exactly who we knew him
to be but from a business point of view
are things you know is he doing good
things for business well sir kind of the
joke is that there like five things I
want to talk about in public I don't
want to talk about religion I don't
wanna talk about politics I don't want
to talk about abortion I don't want to
talk about sex and I don't want to talk
about Donald Trump because whatever you
say yeah I'm gonna get all I'm gonna get
attacked I'm gonna get hate mail from
one side and probably from both sides so
I will say that there are some things
President Trump has done that I like and
there's some things I don't like
obviously I like those tax cuts I think
they're good for the economy and good
for business on the other hand now we're
doing tariffs on steel and aluminum as
protectionism I know that's bad for the
economy so I'm not I'm not cheering that
one on so I can't say whether Hillary
would have been better or worse because
we don't know we don't get to do the
controlled experiment but I can say that
it's better when power alternates if you
only got two parties when one power when
one party stays in power too long more
bad things happen and so shifting around
I'm a great believer in split government
where they just squabble with each other
and nothing ever gets done because if
nothing ever gets done then nothing bad
ever happens and and people can go about
their lives
so I'm not a huge optimist about
government solving our problems well
we'll leave it there thank you so much
we've been talking with John Mackay the
co-founder and CEO of Whole Foods John
thanks for talking Teresa thanks Nick
for reason I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]